all right Richard Richard uh where you
from originally where'd you grow up I
grew up in actually grew up around a lot
uh my mom moved around a lot but uh
Inland Empire California mhm uh spent a
lot of time in Ontario mostly head say
Norco Maroma tell me about your family
growing up uh I am one of four so I have
an older brother who's passed um an
older sister me and then a younger half
sister who I is just my regular sister I
don't really like
uh
and well that my half sister didn't come
into to the picture until after um my my
dad and my mom
divorced um so was the three of us for a
little bit um I had a pretty good life
like a pretty I was pretty lucky I'd say
um I didn't I didn't really want for a
whole lot you know um there was like
struggle with the family and stuff like
that but uh my dad was a great provider
my mom she was a teacher my dad was a
sprinkler fitter worked a lot in LA and
stuff like a lot of roots out here
um so uh growing up wasn't too bad um
probably one of the bigger things in in
like our lives at least as our family
was uh my brother uh he had had a lot of
like what we' come to find out way later
in life was a paranoid
schizophrenic uh with uh with like
violent tendencies he was like dangerous
um uh but growing up he would he would
self-medicate with drugs and so like
that was like super hard on the
household cuz he'd be in and out um it
started with him being addicted you
know uh stealing stuff from the house
you know my dad and my my stepdad
fighting with my brother like it it it
was pretty crazy
um so growing up with that that that was
pretty nuts
um my uh my sister she was she did she
did pretty good uh she did pretty good
in school and stuff like that but like
we were all kind of like uh caught in
this whole thing like with the family
and stuff like that like divorce really
can like spin spin some stuff around for
like a family you know what I mean uh
the whole dynamic and stuff my my
stepdad he did really good when he came
into the picture so it was we're my when
my mom left I believe I was around
like 7 months old and so my brother was
my brother was four years older than me
my sister was 3 years old than they and
then it was me and it was oddly enough
the way that was placed I like I would
end up tell my parents that like I kind
of felt like I was the reason why kind
of like my mom went crazy you know what
I mean it was hard to let that go for a
long time cuz
like that's when like all the problems
with my brother really started like
coming like really about was when my mom
got pregnant with me and she'd tell me
that like yeah she'd be like holding me
like crying with my brother pounding on
the door trying to figure out like what
to do with everybody like she didn't
have a whole lot of help and so I guess
she expressed that to my father and not
a whole lot really changed so she just
she ended up
leaving um this is all just stuff that
I've gathered and been told you know I
was really young at the
time um so yeah like that kind
of was like a little bit hard for us for
a little while um and then my mom met my
stepdad uh and they started like getting
together and he was he was a good
provider like we traveled a lot cuz of
him him like he when when he came into
the picture like he he he did the thing
and it was really like we we went down
to Mexico a lot like that like when
you're a kid and like the stuff just
like happens like you don't you don't
think about it but like yeah I remember
as a kid we go to Rosarito a lot like
once a year we go to Vegas like we we
did a lot of stuff he's a he's an old
biker like you know so like we we we
like he liked to travel uh Grand Canyon
did all kinds of stuff like he did a
really really really good job you know
um so yeah back to my brother uh growing
up there would be drugs coming in later
in life you know we'd be both me and my
brother would put on riddlin because of
our ADHD um I don't know if that had
anything to do I know that like a lot of
my other friends that had have been
addicted to methan
venominefigs
uh so uh fast forwarding like my brother
pretty much is in and out of the house
like my my D my stepdad can't really
deal with him because he's like stealing
[__] cuz he's like on meth and stuff
like that and then
like he ends up getting kicked out of
the house and goes to like halfway
house and all in the middle of this like
I'm in grade school and I'm starting to
go up and
um really just like my sister is in the
same school as I am at the time and my
brother had gotten actually kicked out
of that school that that all this
happened in so uh in the middle of all
this like going on um there was a
teacher there that had uh uh seen like
pretty much like a need like
for my mom to like get some help you
know so we basically like reached out to
her was like yeah like so you know he's
struggling here you know with these with
like some specific stuff that I think I
can help him with so he basically set it
up with my mom that he would like take
me home sometimes after
school and
uh yeah so when un unbeknownst to
anybody up until recently when he was
doing that um he would uh sexually abuse
me when he take me when he took me to
his
house um uh it started off like kind of
easy you know like just some certain
things like touching and stuff like that
to full on like
um I mean pretty much anything you can
imagine it went on for a while like
almost a year like throughout the school
year you know being with him what grade
were you in uh that would have been like
fourth or fifth
grade yeah yeah um and like my mom had
worked like she didn't know you know but
she had worked in the same um if she had
worked in the same school like in
literally in the same building like the
the way the building set up like she
worked like four classrooms down from
like nobody knew you know and when
you're that young like you don't
you you don't know what to I didn't know
what to say I didn't know it you know
what I mean
and yeah so that that stayed buried up
until like
uh uh uh up until recently actually like
this past like right before Co all this
came
out um but yeah like so my brother's in
and out of the house he goes to halfway
houses he ends up going to a halfway
house over in like uh uh I'm sorry
Marietta
um like out in the country in
Marrietta and uh so it's just like my
sister and I you know and then she kind
of falls into the same kind of thing for
a little bit and gets cleaned up or like
she doesn't stay long in that you know
just like we were kind of coping you
know and
uh I don't know what that is like
why what that is in like you know if we
saw it my brother or if I saw it my
sister why but we all kind of like fell
into the same thing you know
um so yeah
um growing up going my brother's out of
the house now uh my sister she takes off
and so it's just me just me and my dad
and my mom and and so I'm like going
back and forth you know still the only
one going back and forth uh cuz that
when like when the divorce you know we
had to go a couple days with my dad a
couple days with my mom's every other
weekend every other Thursday stuff like
that um so by this point I'm the only
one uh going there and I'm I'm
self-medicating on anything it started
out with like alcohol like was like you
know like anything um my my mom and my
my stepdad they had they were you know
they were in like the biker community so
they had a pretty good like liquor
cabinet so that's kind of like where it
started like small there and then
uh I
had
started to work with a buddy of mine's
dad and in that household a friend like
or acquaintance of mine he would do meth
and I had never done it or seen it
before I've heard it I like kind of knew
what it was but I didn't I've never seen
it and then uh just one day we're
hanging
out um and he was like yeah you know you
I was cleaning the backyard at like I
was in my teens you I was cleaning the
backyard at one of his at his house and
he was like yeah if you like you know
you're in to hit hit this and like
you'll be done like before the end of
the day you know and that was it like I
took one hit and I was
hooked um one of the things I I never
really talked about was uh from the
abuse I started having night terres I
never understood what they were I just
be like something's like like squishing
me like it was like a like a ball like a
hairy ball would squish me and I'd wake
up and like full on sweats and like
shaking and like I never said anything
my I didn't I never brought it up to my
parents cuz like I didn't know you know
but I thought they were just like
nightmares but like they I've come to
find out now like looking back what they
were you know um and your biker parents
didn't find
out I they were just dealing with my
brother and my sister and like I didn't
I I I don't know I I don't to this day I
don't know why I never like said
anything like you know I never I never
like hey like I don't
know like parts of it are complet like
and I've heard it here before too it's
like cuz there's parts that they come in
like there were these really Vivid
flashes of like these and they come and
sometimes like new ones will come up you
know and
and it's very common that people won't
find out the the kid stays silent yeah
yeah and the only reason why I brought
it up is because a friend like there was
a a classmate of mine that she like hit
me up in 2019 and like I I guess like I
felt like obligated like responsible
like it wasn't just me cuz if it was me
I could just bury it and like trust like
I tell you like there's health issues
like I've had seizures since this like
yeah yeah and I I'm working with my
doctor I don't know exactly but it seems
like as com I started having seizures
right after all this came up you know
what I mean I've never had seizures
before it's like that I'm not conspiracy
theorists but that or like the vaccine
but I don't I don't know like that's the
thing like it's the trauma like seizures
are a thing you know it can't happen so
I research I have done I don't know but
like
I I would have never brought it up I
would have never like really I would I
don't think I would have you know what I
mean but it's it's now there like so
yeah somebody else
and apparently knowing this the the dude
that it is it's like more than just us
you know we're just the ones that were
we came forward you know
and
it like I
just this dude's like still out there
like they couldn't really do anything
they couldn't really
like like they could but not fully you
know and that's what like that's the
worst thing is like that's why at the
end of it's
like nothing really happen happens you
know to that dude which sucks like I
guess I should have brought it up sooner
I don't know how does that make you
feel
um like a little
like like I don't believe in system like
as it works I'm sure you've seen and
we've seen around you know like like the
systems definitely fails people at times
you know and like it doesn't act when it
should kind of thing you or it doesn't
you you know that's what it feels like
you know since even all this has gone on
there's been like huge divide between my
family like baby's mom and I were like
we're we're good now but it's like it's
just a huge hiccup I can you can imagine
anybody's life you know and like the
relationships that follow like I I I
would end up like the only reason why I
never really liked meth but the what I
didn't like I like not sleeping I didn't
have night tears I didn't I like the
euphoria that comes with it like so I
was sold immediately you know it wasn't
like once I quit it was like yeah it's
dumb like I couldn't go back and do that
stuff again I lik my sleep you know what
I mean I think my my only voice is like
marijuana you know what I mean like I I
do like mushrooms every once in a while
or stuff like that but I don't do like
anything really hard anymore you know
especially with that like everything
that uh fent alls in you know I it's too
scary but uh yeah so growing up um would
end up uh self-medicating for a while
get kicked out of the house steal from
my parents like doing dumb [__] um just
trying to trying to trying to stay high
you know for a while and it wasn't right
you know um looking back obviously like
I should have I should have I wish I
would have like therapy or something
like that you know
my my brother and my my sister they they
they they got a lot of attention for a
little bit you know my
my my mom would it would go down so like
after my brother it was my sister and
then my sister then it was me you know
and she was trying her best to do what
she can with what she had you know but
it wasn't we weren't we weren't going to
listen you know the drugs are too
powerful and this just happened in the
last few years um came out
the the abuse the the the abuse came out
uh 2019 so right before like Co hit
um how old are you now I'm 39 you lived
with this for decades yeah yeah uh I I
probably would have you know it just
it's something that
like
um I don't know and even now like I said
like the seizures and stuff like that
and just health problems I've had since
like like I don't know that I've even
wanted to even come up like you know
there's there's there's like litigation
and stuff going on that I can't get like
too far into and stuff like I told you
but
like I don't is it worth it you know
like with everything that's come up it's
like I I did it for a friend of mine cuz
I know that like she's going through it
too and like she deserves better and
like it wasn't just me and that's what's
like really [__] up you know it's like
how many other people you know
but yeah I I would end up
um moving up to Oregon so uh I'm down
here for a little while high school
barely graduate high school I'm already
like fully addicted to meth before I
graduate high
school um my stepdad and my mom had
moved up to Oregon so like I was down
here for a little bit after high school
and then I followed them up and back
then it's like 2004
um
I I didn't know that like that's
actually like one of the worst places to
go if you're trying to like quit you
know at the time so I go up there and I
do good for a while um but I I slip up
and I end up getting into the wrong
crowd up there because I I honestly
think it was I wasn't really dealing
with like you know the stuff you know
just it was constantly just running from
something you know so I would fall back
in there get kicked out of the house up
there would end up living like on the
streets in and out of Apartments like
with like a bunch of people without a
bunch of people like
around um and I would do that probably
that would go on for a couple years you
know until I finally like
uh I finally one day just stopped like
like I I remember vividly like well
there's up to that point so I was we
were I was in the apartment with my
buddy Pat if you're still out there
um his aunt was growing
marijuana and back then when uh like you
you she had uh leukemia so she was able
to grow for her medical stash so she
actually came by with like a big old
green uh Crisco um oil jar and what she
said she basically told Pat night she's
like I know what you guys are doing if
you quit I'll give you this if if you
keep going then like you don't don't
even like think about it you know like
I'm not going to give you anymore kind
of thing you know so basically what she
was doing is she was giving edible
marijuana for us if we quit doing meth
and
venominon we stopped buying meth we
started eating brownies and basically
like offset like the high you know uh
ended up getting off of meth made the
terrible decision after a couple months
to start like selling Coke so we were
selling Coke for a little while and then
him and I had a falling out after
selling Coke for a little while and
that's when like I actually ran into
another one our our friends Ron um he
let me stay at his house until for like
3 more months cleaned up and then I
moved back down down here with my dad in
California that was probably back in
like 7 so I was out here ever
since um but right like on the way in
calling my dad I remember uh being it
like you know he people how you have to
be done but I remember the time when I
was so we were selling Coke we had a
falling out and then so I was on my own
and I was in Sandy Oregon they were
building houses on the way down so I was
living in the houses as they were like
building them so like I'd just move a
house down move a house down I wasn't a
dick so I'd like clean up after myself I
wouldn't like you know it wouldn't leave
like a mess for the construction workers
or anything like that but I remember one
night um I had called a friend of mine
and she was uh McKenzie she was like
where where are you and I'm like I'm in
a house I'm at a buddy's house and I was
just like setting in that like what I'm
doing and like what was going on I
remember that day in particular was like
when I quit like doing everything like I
I quit doing math I quit doing Coke like
I didn't want to do that stuff
anymore so I cleaned up and I came back
down I mean that and to be honest that
wouldn't be the last time I would
struggle with that later in life too um
I would come back down and
uh once I got back down here went to
machinist school started getting my life
together and getting it going you know
um but it definitely like this stuff has
like been a struggle throughout my
entire life even up until now you know
where when my brother now came back um
he was doing Trucking he was doing all
right but then he got a a brain tumor I
forgot the name of his like malignant
brain tumor but this this is a
schizophrenic brother yeah this is like
this is so this is right up into 201
like
17 he
um he was in Georgia he was out there at
a halfway house um um so
they he was like he had like when you're
out there and like the money that they
were getting from the government is
basically for the halfway house and so
they give him like a little like
dividend of the money and so the halfway
house would get but he had everything he
used to like if had need any wash
clothes all that stuff was there he
didn't have to worry about n so
apparently he for was going over to a
neighbor's house and like hanging out
and he'd come back and beg him for money
and so like when he's begging for money
you know obviously they knew what he was
kind of doing so I don't know the exact
story but apparently he got a hold of
something of his own like his own drugs
and he brought him over and he like did
a line and he passed out and he started
like bleeding from his nose so the
people at that house picked him up and
like straight traffic Style just dropped
him in front of the halfway house and
took off and they brought him in um the
people at the house brought him into the
hospital and so I guess I was just a
catalyst he had a brain tumor but like
that's when they found it like when when
they took him in the hospital so my mom
my my mom my dad actually flew out to
Georgia grabbed my brother bought him
back my mom had him in the house and he
basically was at hospice at my mom's
house um they were able to take out the
brain tumor but it was just like a 5050
thing cuz the way the brain tumor was
like the doctor explained it if you look
at it wrong it's like super aggressive
and it expands so they try to take out
they took out they able to take out 90%
but they had to leave 10% cuz it was
like functioning parts of his brain and
with that 10% after 4 months it grew
back twice his size so he ended up dying
in hospice here in California back in
um which you know my mom was my mom and
my dad like
they I I don't I don't blame them for
like the stuff that happened or like
what they did they they did I I there's
times and I'm not going to like there's
times that I definitely like had like
animosities and like anger and stuff but
like they they did the best they can
with what they had you know and I
totally appreciate him for that you know
and like it just they were did they were
dealt like a rough deck you know my
brother me like my sister like they just
they just then some people have rougher
hands I suppose yeah
like they just they just he got dealt a
rough hand you know you get lucky you
get bad luck too
right um so my brother passes and that
that kind of sent shock waves through
the family you know but and weirdly like
something like that it kind of brought
us closer together cuz like my my mom my
step my mom my dad they hadn't talked
like that in years you know and they
were able to do that so it
was it it was cool to see that like and
them being able to get along you know
what I mean and like people come
together
like my stepdad was like letting my
brother back in the house after
everything you
know it it it really did bring the
family together in like a weird
way do you feel like all the stuff you
went through the sexual abuse when you
were young has impacted I mean that's
the reason for your drug use and the
reason for your a th% yeah yeah like I
wouldn't the the biggest thing was like
with with that was like I get like like
I I was saying like night terrors like
those I like my sleep and like I wasn't
a huge anybody that knows me like I'm an
interject person you know it's not meth
isn't my drug you know and I just
something that like the euphoria that
you get from the dopamine and not
sleeping like that's what I enjoyed I
didn't you know that's especially at
that time you know I just I didn't I
didn't
have I didn't have like a better way you
know what I mean I wasn't given therapy
at the time and like at that time and I
don't blame my family but they were
dealing with my brother and my sister
and stuff at the time you know what I
mean like they that like they I was kind
of like pushed aside for a second you
know and I totally get it like my my dad
kicked me out because he's like after
dealing with my brother and stealing
from him and stuff like he just didn't
want to deal with it he's you know go do
your own thing for a little bit you know
I don't blame him I don't blame him um
um but yeah 100% like the drug addiction
is definitely from the abuse is trying
to trying to to cope you know and trying
to feel better with like you know what
life is and what that is what what
that's supposed to be about you
know where do you think your life goes
from
here um I'm actually so I got my LLC
going uh I'm a welder now I I I I love
what I do I'm not a huge fan of where I
do it
um uh I'm working on doing like making
the LLC bigger and do a couple things
with that one I'm want to be an
entrepreneur uh within the next couple
years you know um with everything going
on yeah I'd like to I'd like to just get
the LLC going and like you know hang out
with my kids more
and really that's the next thing for me
um and this your your Predator is a free
man I don't know what to to do with that
yeah I I don't know what to do with that
that
that I just accept that as like a a
failure in the system like
what I I mean
I what am I supposed to do with that
Mark
like it's a rough thing to deal with
yeah like I'm not a person about like
revenge and [__] but like I am a person
about Justice you know what I
mean revenge is not the answer yeah but
like and that's at some point like isn't
that what it is though is that is that
just my like is I guess is that my
lesson that I have to learn you know or
I have to
like the the ultimate patience you know
what I mean like yeah that did happen so
what you know like that and that's the
way I try to like I have kids dude I
have a little dude like I have little
kids that are watching me you know and
like I have to set a good example you
know and I want to for the world like
that's that like one of the main reasons
why I wanted to talk to you was cuz it's
just the same thing tell like treat
people better you know like that's just
treat just try to treat people better
try to be cool try to smile at somebody
cuz like this [__] sucks dude like this
shit's going to suck too if we don't
find a way to like come together and
like really do it together like that's I
used to work with OFA uh Obama for
America like when uh back in 2008 when
got elected is one of my one of the cool
things that I did um and I I think about
this like when when we talk about
Revolution dude and like we used to like
when I thought about like it would be
like us against them like we're going to
do it together and now it doesn't feel
like that and that's what sucks and like
that's what I
don't I don't know I get both sides CU
like the younger coming up like the
young kids that I'm sure you talked to
too like and the ones that I work with
man they're incredible they're so smart
they're so smart and it gives me so much
hope for the future but then like you
also see like you know everything that's
happening in the media and everything
it's
like what are we doing you
know like when did we lose our way I
don't know I always felt like we're
going to do this together and like I
just wish we'd feel like that again you
know that
like it was us against them you know
that like we're the ones that have to
like pay the taxes we're the ones that
drive on the freeways we're the ones
that deal with like you know like we we
are the ones that have to do it it's
like we forget that you know I think
like and not only that that's why I do
think that like what your your show's
important too is like telling these
stories you know people like everybody
struggles man everybody goes through it
if you don't you're lucky you're you're
lucky you made it lucky and like you won
the lottery yeah yeah yeah exactly
exactly you know it's it's shocking how
common these stories are things things
like what you went through they hear all
the time crazy and like we just got to
keep doing it right like you still got
to go to work you know you still got to
raise a family and stuff and like I want
to do that the best way possible you
know what I mean I want to do that with
my friends I want to do cool stuff with
my friends I want to you're breaking the
cycle by being a good dad raising good
kids protecting them from that kind of
stuff MH trying my best man my that's a
great thing my my baby's mom dude I I
couldn't I couldn't ask for anybody
better right next to me dude I couldn't
I couldn't ask for anybody better like
she's a godsend like the mother of my
kids is the most beautiful person I
[__] know dude I can say that without
like a shadow of a doubt man that woman
like she's been through so much with me
you know and the kids and like my kids
my my daughter is so incredibly smart my
son the same thing you know I got so
[__] lucky you know and all I want to
do is just like good times for people
dude I don't want to like w we're like
looking at War and I think I heard Joe
Rogan said this like dude when I was
younger I never I thought we'd be Beyond
this idea that we're like at a World War
like we're about to do this like dude
that's so scary you know I got kids like
I don't want to do that you know the
same thing you got you got kids too yeah
like it's so scary you know and that's
what I I mean I came out here to say
it's like we we need to like come
together more somehow better you know
like Beyond whatever these politics are
you know CU it isn't at the end of the
day it's just us in our houses man and
our jobs you know none of that stuff
really matters like that it matters
obviously when we're dropping bombs but
like yeah it's a crazy
world it doesn't seem to be getting any
less crazy
as we get older
too
I yes and no and I think and that's one
I think you have that Insight I this
particular job I work at now um I'm a
welder like we do mrf so it's a
recycling reman like so we do recycling
centers and like re uh re we redo them
we like build new ones whatever they
need you know we go all over the world
for that stuff but what I found in like
these these like something special about
these like 25 26y olds coming in right
now man they're really smart man they're
really smart some of the kids I'm
running into and I'm able to work with
are like some of the most incredible
people I've ever worked with you know
and so it does give me hope yeah but at
the same time it does to your point yeah
it's like it still feels crazier than it
ever has been like you know just I don't
know I don't know what we do man I I
feel like we need to talk to each other
more is the only thing I know how to do
you know really well I can work hard but
like I know how to talk to people I know
how to like you know build relationships
and friends and stuff you know but like
I I think we should be friends more I
think we should try like work harder to
like really like pay attention to each
other's needs and like let like little
things be little things man these these
politics are are killing us man they're
like literally killing us that's how I
feel I felt that way for a long time
this is somebody I used to work with OFA
man that was a long time
ago but I I don't think it's it's
political as much as just us being
friends and like being neighborly being
more loving yeah yeah
100% it's not going to hurt
anybody all right Richard thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
good luck with everything thank
you